welcome to this video playing even yell
at ski what are those guys doing at the
moment yep playing h4 and a for stuff
okay um so let's think about it c5 or
yeah okay I'm going to stop this pawn
and try to pick it up with Bishop g4 at
some later stage it's really just a
liability to spawn yeah playing with
pressure in the center is always a good
idea after the opponent has some has
played many moves I on there on the edge
of the board like this this pawn advance
um let's see maybe capturing its ok
maybe Bishop before just develop stuff
and get castling prepared okay
hmm yeah okay i don't know i mean i
don't know maybe if i should keep maybe
I should keep queens on but this is not
bad definitely not okay
yeah if i play c5 he will play Queenie 5
check and Bishop you 6 young but still I
still I should do that I think Jack
intending to go d4 if possible I don't
know maybe a three-year a3 Bishop takes
pawn takes
he can also casts a long maybe just
trying to ignore the form now this is
what I expected but hmm ok Bishop f5 he
will play before which looks kinda
jackass trophic so I have to take but
what now but now really Queen B 2 is
probably just castling him and all that
didn't make make much sense mmm yeah
that's not such a great position
actually my castle he even has Bishop
age 6 m well that's disappointing any
anything concrete that I can do add this
bishop age six movies is really an
annoyance I have Bishop g4 though yeah
come on I need to play not for much far
behind yeah this is this is my plan
reply but he's got Queen g5 Quincy five
saves the day
yeah very unfortunate is that I cannot
even play rook e8 or something like that
because then after Queen g5 I have no
way to cover that
but if not way to cover the pawn
I 98 this is really a law yeah nothing
else I really don't see a movie you can
maybe just take a play age 60 mm now you
can do that actually oh wow what a game
he has overlooked this move but probably
doesn't matter okay yeah I mean happen
this is a terrible position but I feel
like it could have been worse as weird
as this may sound can I get some sort of
counter play with queen bee tool maybe I
can no it's not so clear how he's
handling his own King position ok I have
to be quick I cannot afford to spend
ages cm this is threatening queen 85 and
if he takes rook the aid for for some
counterplay really
no this is not not clear at all anymore
he's got this check which is which is so
unfortunate ok Queen f5 and he's got
this check on b7 ok check I can go time
warning i'm going to go here but you can
take a play Queen g3 check of course but
he still will be in this pin on the sea
three Pawn check check we can give
another check yeah you can do all that
ok now i can take Queen takes rook what
not enough really check yeah but I have
to play
Jeff is hoping to win by by a meeting
attack which may be will will will be
successful because I have no time
whatsoever maybe the position is also i
can go on he can go there I happen ja
maybe maybe has a meeting attack
possible Queen f6 check my twin check
they are Queen e5 unfortunately no come
on well that was that was a really silly
game then after age for you definitely
want to win because it simply idiotic of
course but I didn't really refute it
yeah up to here of course it's okay yeah
but I'm doing some some things that I
probably not really helped me okay this
now he took and queen d 4 here we need
to start to look for improvements yeah
it's very simple actually i'm queen
after Queenie seven white is in a
terrible position really threatening c5
and deform I just need to do this that's
very easy actually problem is he
basically has to castle now after that I
cancel myself and now he has this week
porn on age 5 which is completely
useless and just a target and I have the
central dominance with the screen be
misplaced so yeah this is a fantastic
position like just it's just much better
him to give you a computer evaluates and
stop fishes on minus 1 point 3 so more
than one pawn which is quite a lot the
thing is that he only hears a couple of
weaknesses while I don't have any ok I
went with this and now yeah yeah after
this position wyd is better yeah it's
just like that I mean one problem is
that after castles I mean I saw the
moon's Bishop f6 of course but I was I
was thinking I could play rook e8 but he
can just play Queen g5 yeah it's very
simple computer actually wants me to
play Queen B 2 and it's not so clear
yeah
yeah actually I think you really let me
have somehow somewhat back into the game
anyway but probably it never really
there really never was anything that I
can do and i'm still a porn down and
he's got the far more dangerous attack
and King e1 is just better than Queens
III m yeah computer accesses the tag
win7 it's it's it's possible as
mentioned in the game I wasn't
completely sure about it it done it is
just such an open can that you probably
cannot defend it okay thanks for
watching